son uno de los incendios más
destructivos en la historia de argelia
decenas de incendios arden en el país
afectando principalmente el norte del
territorio dejando decenas de muertos el
fuego ha derribado casas y ha obligado a
cientos a buscar refugio el área más
afectada es tizi ouzou en la región de
cabilia
como verán al fuego en todas partes no
hemos visto el gobierno acá no tenemos
un estado la gente es el gobierno viva
los miembros del equipo de protección
civil
entre los fallecidos hay soldados que
les salvaron la vida civiles y lucharon
para combatir los fuegos otros quedaron
con heridas de gravedad el presidente de
esta nación se pronunció al respecto con
profunda tristeza y dolor recibo la
noticia de la muerte de 25 miembros del
ejército nacional popular luego de que
lograran salvarle la vida a más de 100
ciudadanos de los incendios en las
montañas de beja ya it is joe show en
medio de esta tragedia rogamos por las
almas de los héroes de esta nación
funcionarios del gobierno han culpado a
pirómanos de haber dado inicio a las
quemas sin embargo no ofrecen evidencia
y se comprometen a compensar a los
afectados
y mostrar como habrán notado y bajo las
directivas del presidente de la
republica una delegación ministerial
conjunta visitó estas áreas esta mañana
para conocer la magnitud de las pérdidas
y la magnitud del desastre confirmamos
que el estado los compensará total y
completamente por estas pérdidas
una ola de calor ha agudizado los
incendios forestales en la región del
mediterráneo afectando gravemente
también a grecia italia y turquía